bonjour françois cocq merci de répondre
à nos questions emmanuel macron n'a pas
encore parlé mais qu'est ce que vous
attendez de son discours
monsieur macro on n'a pas encore parlé
mais on a déjà des signes de ce qu'il
veut ce qu'il veut faire de part sa
visite à macron ça dit un peu
exceptionnel il s'est quand même déplacé
avec sept ministres pendant trois jours
chacun voit donc ce n'est pas ce une
simple visite sur le seul sur sur le
territoire c'est aussi un moment fort de
la campagne présidentielle qu'il entend
qu'il entend mener voyez ce qui est un
petit peu cocasse quand même c'est que
c'est au bout de quatre ans de son
mandat quatre ans et demi même de son
mandat que monsieur macron le supporters
de l'om découvre finalement que
marseille n'est pas qu'un club de foot
mais c'est aussi une ville et une fille
une ville avec des besoins assez urgent
alors que va faire monsieur manon ma
macron la même chose que ce qu'il fait
depuis le début de sa visite c'est à
dire d effet d'annonce il va saupoudré
beaucoup d'argent mais sans qu'on sache
réellement si les résultats seront à la
hauteur il va livrer un discours dans
quelques instants qui est intitulé si
j'ai bien compris marseillan grands
voiliers je parlais de foot ya un
instant c'est un petit peu comme
monsieur marc courte le président de
l'om qui dit c'est le champion ce
project donc ce sont des effets
d'annoncé et derrière mais en foot les
supporters de l'om attendent toujours
des résultats et il est à espérer que
les citoyens et les marseillaises et les
marseillais n'auront pas à attendre
aussi en vain des résultats vous avez
dit emmanuel macron a dû attendre la fin
de son quinquennat pour s'occuper de la
deuxième ville de france mais il ya
quand même eu en souvient david khalifa
vient de le rappeler là le drame de la
rue d'aubagne
et avec eux
un chèque qui avaient été signés le
résultat se font toujours attendre
certes mais il y avait quand même ça
il y avait eu ça mais monsieur macron
court après la vie tout simplement court
après la vie des françaises et les
français courent ici en l'occurrence
après l'avis des marseillaise et des
marseillais il faut que des drames
interviennent pour qu'enfin il se décide
à réagir il n'a pas été capable pendant
son qu'un pendant son quinquennat de
faire un état des lieux et d'anticiper
les besoins et ils sont connus pour
marseille tant du côté de la santé que
du côté du système éducatif que du côté
de la sécurité monsieur macron se
déplace aujourd'hui parce qu' il ne peut
pas faire autrement quand on voit les
drames qui émaillent cette ville depuis
maintenant des semaines le début de
l'année et même de plus longs mois
encore donc monsieur macron finalement
n'est pas le maître de l'horreur des
horloges qu'il prétend être
il vient à marseille d'une certaine
façon contraints et forcés et je dois le
dire il faut se méfier quand même de
cette façon de faire qui consiste à
territorialisée la politique les besoins
à marseille sont immenses ils sont sans
doute exacerbée par rapport à bien
d'autres endroits sur le territoire mais
il ne faudrait pas que la visite ait des
annonces de monsieur macron à marseille
fasse oublier les besoins qui sont tout
aussi importants dans d'autres endroits
du territoire sur les mêmes sujets
l'hôpital la crise sanitaire est une
crise de l'hôpital public parce que
depuis des années on n'y avait pas les
moyens et monsieur macro ont fait partie
de celles et ceux qui ont contribué à
cet état de fait la crise dans
l'éducation nationale c'est le fait qu'
il n'y a pas un problème de recrutement
les enseignants parce que les métiers ne
sont pas attractifs parce que les
besoins ne sont pas fournis voyez les
extracteurs d'air monsieur macron est à
marseille le maire de marseille lui a
fait une démarche qui consiste à essayer
de répondre il dit pas que c'est la
seule solution sa passe est évidemment à
part la vaccination par les gestes
barrière mais a essayé d'aider la
démarche pour maintenir les élèves à
l'école en fournissant des extracteurs
d'air dans les écoles marseillaise eh
bien monsieur macro et monsieur blanc
caire ne le font pas il considéra que le
sel extracteurs d'air valable c'est le
ministre de l'éducation nationale parce
que c'est lui qui brasse le plus
d'heures eh bien ce ne sont pas des
réponses dignes par rapport aux enjeux
qui sont ceux de ce pays et ceux de
cette ville
france un couac 1
souvient en 2013 le premier ministre à
l'époque sous le mandat de françois
hollande c'était jean marc ayrault il
avait annoncé 3 milliards d'euros pour
marseille pour les transports la
sécurité l'emploi on a l'impression que
c'est la même chose la bis repetita les
des annonces de jean marc ayrault à
l'époque ça en est où maintenant
pourquoi est ce que manuel m'apprend est
obligé d'intervenir
ce qui s'est passé sous le sous le
mandat de monsieur de monsieur héros
lorsqu'il était premier ministre c'est
aussi vous vous en souvenez qu'il ya une
grande réforme territoriale qui a été
mise en place qui est une catastrophe
cette réforme territoriale c'est la
métropolisation voyez celle qui fait que
l'on nous on prétendait limiter les
doublons mais qu'en réalité on a rajouté
des couches de superstructure qui dilue
la responsabilité d'aider des élus et
qui finalement les seules entrées
siffler hier ce n'est pas au niveau de
l'état sait c'est pas au niveau du
territoire qu'est ce que vous proposez
non ce que je suis en train de dire
c'est que entre marseille et la
métropole de marseille et les villes
autour la manière dont tout ça est gérée
c'est un filet percée qui a été fait
donc que l'état vienne aujourd'hui dire
qui a besoin de remettre de l'argent
dans les hôpitaux a marseille c'est vrai
qu'il dise qu'il faut mettre de l'argent
dans l'école a marseille c'est vrai
pour la sécurité à marseille c'est vrai
mais un que ne l'at il pas fait plus tôt
et 2 que n'en a t-il pas que les besoins
qui sont ceux de marseille exerce existe
aussi à l'échelle du pays voilà ce que
je dis on en est au bout de quatre ans
et demi du quinquennat tout le monde a
bien compris que la stratégie de
monsieur macron pour tenter de se faire
réélire et de dire ce que je vais lancer
pendant ce quinquennat portera ses
fruits si vous me réalisés pendant le
second quinquennat eh bien nous ce qu on
est obligé de constater et le covin ne
suffit pas à expliquer les montre
comment de monsieur macron c'est que les
promesses et qui sont celles de 2007
n'ont pas été tenues merci à françois
cocq